például az egyik ami engem nagyon
megérintett amikor beszélgettél az az
hogy kell figyelj a a juniorokra akik
most csatlakoztak a játékhoz és kell
tanítgasd őket és és és szeretsz is
ezzel foglalkozni valójában egy jó
játékos ahhoz hogy jó legyen ahhoz le
kell hajoljon a kezdőkhöz és kell
segítsenőket hát igen hát van aki
figyelmen kívül hagyja teljesen őket
például én is most ha versenyre készülök
és van még két-három órám akkor nyilván
nem azzal foglalkozok hogy valaki bejön
a teambbe és azt mondja hogy
csinálsz-e nekem egy
vagy megmutatod ezt hogy kell beállítani
elmagyaráz akkor nyilván nem tudok
segíteni mert a versenyre fókuszálok de
amikor van időm akkor segítünk
[Zene]